- Jean-Marc Arbaud, merci
beaucoup.
- Bonsoir.
- Alors, est-ce que Monsieur
Arbaud vous convainc?
- Ce qu'ils nous disent que moi
j'ai un modèle à faire. On prend
le moins de risque possible
d'enlever des délais et en
présence finance.
Avec ce modèle d'affaires on ne
peut pas prendre ce genre de
risque. Maintenant,
techniquement ces risques
peuvent se prendre ils se sont
prient très souvent Montréal.
L'hôtel Bonaventure est
construit. On a construit le
métro sous l'hôtel Bonaventure
après qu'on ait construit
l'hôtel laissé entre nos drôles
et un hôtels. Il y a encore des
trains qui rentrent dans l'hôtel
Bonaventure. C'est possible. Le
carrée vigie qui vient d'être
rénovée sous le cas rédigé il y
a
Orange qui passe.
Il y a une autoroute.
Ça été rénové a été compliqué.
Ça prend des spécialistes.
- Je ne sais pas dans quelle
mesure Kuller les études vous
continuent à dire : c'est encore
possible.
- Bien sûr que c'est possible.
C'est tout à fait possible.
Mais ça aurait un impact sur les
coûts. Il y a aucun entrepreneur
qui voudrait entrer dans ce
projet avec une obligation de
payer lui-même des délais et des
coûts supplémentaires. Ça c'est
vrai. Mais c'est peut-être...
c'est à cause de la formule.
- On devrait payer ça.
- Non non.
On a dépensé 2 milliards de
dollars de coût du projet. On a
dépassé de deux ans ou si le
coût du projet. Alors lorsqu'on
dit dans la phase de revue zéro
dépassements de coûts et zéro
dépassement de délais et zéro
risque. Bien sûr qu'avec ces 30,
il faut que tu fasses en aérien.
- Là, la caresse un petit bout
dans le sous-sol. 500 m pour
faire une façon qui va raccorder
le Montréal souterrain.
Est-ce que ça vous a convaincu?
- Bien moi ce que j'ai aimé ça
transparence. Rappelons-nous la
semaine dernière on a parlé ont
été attendons de voir les études
pour se positionner. Je pense
qu'il était clair. Tout est
possible, à quel coût et à quels
risques? Cette question qu'on
doit se poser actuellement. Ils
nous ont montré ils nous ont
prouvé parce que moi je ne suis
pas ingénieur, ils nous ont
prouvé moi j'ai lu le rapport
cet après-midi, ce n'est pas
possible. C'est trop risqué de
la faire comme on voulait le
faire. La seule partie qui était
possible, beaucoup moins de
troubles, c'est la partie qui
nous en présente aujourd'hui.
Donc il y a une partie qui est
possible de le faire dans
certains groupes on ne le sait
pas encore. C'est la prochaine
étape combien ça va coûter.
Aujourd'hui nous disent OK il y
a ce scénario qui ne sont pas
bons. Il y en a un qu'on retient
c'est le dernier.
C'est la compagnie espagnole.
Mais on ne sait pas encore mis à
l'écouter. On ne sait pas encore
cette partie. C'est possible oui
de le faire une partie du tunnel
sans prendre les risques parce
que même si on décide elle avec
une autre structure même si on
n'est pas ingénieur ni toi ni
moi Luc, on ne sait pas si une
compagnie va prendre le risque
de la part. Il y a tout ça
aussi. Il faut y aller où tout
est possible.
La possibilité sur la table.
C'est encore évolutif. Il y aura
des consultations. Il y aura le
dépôt de l'architecture de la
structure. Après ça il va y
avoir le BAPE.
- Donc Luc,
est-ce que le mieux n'est pas
l'ennemi du bien?
À force de vouloir quelque chose
de magnifique extraordinaire...
- je comprends très bien votre
question.
La laideur comme la beauté ce
sont des cumuls. Le cumul " dans
la laideur... par exemple une
structure aérienne, c'est
ombragé il y a du vent. Il y a
des gens qui s'installent avec
détente de sous. C'est arrivé à
Philadelphie. C'est arrivé à
Chicago. C'est des choses qui
sont possibles. On ne peut pas
nous garantir ce qui va se
passer dans 20 ans. Dans la
partie qui descend par exemple
pour le centre-ville, c'est un
refuge parfait. C'est un abri
parfait plus marrant. Elle
combat grillager cette partie-
là? Il y a des choses que la
caisse ne peut pas garantir.
Est-ce que ça va faire dévaluer
les rez-de-chaussée sur la rue
de Sherbrooke. Arrivé en mai
2000 dans le monde. La laideur
est un cumul de petites choses.
La caisse les premiers éléments
mais peut-être d'autres éléments
vont venir...
- c'est un cumul.
Tu vois le côté noir.
Je reste à côté du métropolitain
mais je vois dans le monde des
gens qui sont... qui ont de
bonnes idées à comme à Shanghai.
On met des bacs à fleurs sur le
bord de l'autoroute. En balcon
de garderie pour enfants. Ils
ont du tapis vert ils ont des
magasins de fruits. Il y a plein
de choses qu'on peut le faire.
Ces surveillants ne donnent qui
vont l'occuper. Le défi c'est
ça. Comme on est capable de
trouver un projet?
- Je suis d'accord avec toi,
mais ce n'est pas ce que la
caisse nous propose.
La ville a aussi un rôle à jouer
là-dedans
- deux secondes chacun.
Comment vont se positionner M.
Coderre et Mme Plante
aujourd'hui?
- Mme Plante...
elle a laissé le vote libre.
Elle a laissé la mère de
Rivière-des-Prairies
et de Pointe-aux-Trembles avait
sorti contre.
- Ce sera aux citoyens de
décider.